les salariés de la santé et du social en
ont ras la blouse nouvelle mobilisation
aujourd'hui partout en france et
notamment à tours à l'appel des
syndicats trois cents manifestants se
sont rassemblés devant l' agence
régionale de santé pour réclamer des
renforts d'effectifs et la prime de 183
euros pour les oubliés du ségur exemple
de ce mal-être les salariés de
l'institut médico-éducatif de
chateaurenaud étaient en grève
aujourd'hui faute de moyens suffisants
l'accompagnement des jeunes en situation
de handicap est de plus en plus
compliqué tristan heckly
réunis pour faire entendre leur voix les
employés de l'institut médico-éducatif
de château renault sont en colère depuis
deux ans il dénonce un dialogue rompu
avec leur hiérarchie et un manque de
reconnaissance
rassemblés ce matin devant leur
établissement ils espèrent pouvoir faire
bouger les lignes en cause un manque de
moyens criant et à tous les locaux qui
sont vétustes des psycho motricienne qui
sont venus avec leurs outils personnels
pour pouvoir faire des séances
l'institut médico-éducatif accueille
près de 120 enfants et adolescents leur
mission accompagner les jeunes souffrant
d'handicap et ceux issus de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance un suivi de plus en
plus compliqués à gérer donc des enfants
qui se retrouvent sans prise en charge à
certains moments et c'est un vrai vrai
problème ça fait entrave à leur avancée
malgré
les projets personnalisés qui sont mis
en place parce que il n'y a pas de
professionnels forcément pour les
encadrer c'est des gens qui se mettent
en arrêt en permanence et c'est beaucoup
de gens qui démissionnent forcément on
est moins on est moins efficients dans
le travail parce que pas suffisamment
nombreux un projet de restructuration de
l'ime a bien été proposé il ya plusieurs
années il prévoyait notamment la
reconstruction complète des locaux très
attendue par le personnel ce chantier
est aujourd'hui au point mort savez
leurs ailes conditions de travail de
tout le monde aujourd'hui on a un site
sur sur l'ime est complètement 18
éclater
une grosse perte de perdition d'énergie
de temps beaucoup de temps passé
aujourd'hui les personnels de l'institut
se disent épuisés ils espèrent être
entendus par leur hiérarchie pour
pouvoir obtenir de meilleures conditions
de travail